Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dimitrov from
Ukraine. Also, a website member. Dmytro,
thank you so much for your support on the Web
site. I very much appreciate that. And if you
unmute yourself, I will be able to talk to you.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Hello. Thank you for coming.
Speaker 1: Pleasure.
Speaker 3: I. I'm not
going to take my much time. I just wanted to
say that I am grateful for your position and
for support of American people. My country.
Speaker 1: You're currently in Ukraine.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I'm from Kiev.
Speaker 1: Are you? I mean,
do you feel safe right now?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I got used to all
this stuff, so. Yeah, I think so.
Speaker 1: And when you say used to, what
are you dealing with on a daily basis?
Speaker 4: Oh, well.
Speaker 3: It's like some
error alerts time to time. But the people I go
to work, people like trying to live their lives,
you know, or not becoming sane or something.
Speaker 1: You know, one of the things that is
incredible to me throw is the degree to which
humans adapt and unthinkable situations become
your everyday reality. And it's simultaneously
heartbreaking, but also incredibly inspiring
that that people adapt. But obviously we
want things to change so that you're not
dealing with air raid sirens on the way to work.
Speaker 3: Yeah I agree people about and yeah,
I'm grateful to American people. And to be
honest that I watch American politics spend
time because you know, a lot of stuff actually
affect us. And I was so nervous of during this
speaker election or since the midterm elections.
So. I think everything is going to be okay.
Speaker 1: I admire your optimism and I
really appreciate you calling in today.
Speaker 3: Thank you. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. There is Demetrius from
Ukraine. Why don't we go? Why don't we go next to
David from Philadelphia and see what's going on
in Philadelphia? David from Philadelphia, welcome
to the program. What is on your mind today? Oh,
no. We might be losing David from Philadelphia,
sir. All right. Well, no, David from Philadelphia.